drives goes to the glass
talk about
all-star ability
you see things like this through the
lane able to finish
[Music]
morant steps back he's got a three it's
him
and it's a five-point game
trying to hit someone in the middle or
let's get moran on the speed driven
morant
pulls up a three good if it goes
with three tenths of a second david
slams his fifth on the scorer's turbo in
frustration at the free throw line
and morant
you let him go the leaning three is in
he had that let me have the limp against
phoenix and here started second half he
started to have that same length again
[Music]
moret elevates and hits
one point
[Applause]
job steps out and open three
tango
[Music]
the largest blown lead in the nba this
year
westbrook stolen by mourinho
with two timeouts remaining did not want
to challenge that but he takes away a
bucket
and a good hustle again here by terry
though coming up with a steal force the
turnover bane
pitches it out
and open three marantz
a new career
[Applause]
[Music]
a perfect six or six a new career high
in three-point mates and 38 points
miranda against westbrook tries to take
him off the bounce he spins he
[Applause]
and actually the grizzlies i should
correct myself they have two timeouts
remaining
seven difference between the two clocks
monk
spins
lebron lost his footing and then threw
it away stolen by tyus jones
the grizzly season turned around when
they bought in on the defensive side and
here on this possession is the reason
why you buy in defensively